tous ceux qui investissent dans le savoir à propos de nous
sont occupés à trouver comment acheminer l'eau à partir des aquifères en Libye
pour étancher la soif de l'Europe.
Telle est notre connaissance de nos ressources en eau
que beaucoup de nos pays ont renoncé
à rendre l'eau potable une présence systématique
dans la vie des Africains,
riches ou pauvres,
hauts et bas,
des régions rurales et urbaines.
Nous acceptons avidement ce que les marchands de misère
et le safari du professorat des études africaines globales,
et leurs aides,
sbires africains apeurés par l'autonomie,
dans le gouvernement, les universités et la société civile
nous disent au sujet de la façon dont la nature a privé l'Afrique
quand il s'agit de la répartition des ressources en eau dans le monde.
Nous sommes satisfaits de faire fonctioner nos villes et habitations rurales
sur les forages.
Comment peut-on faire fonctionner des métropoles sur des forages et des puits ?
L'Afrique a-t-elle une crise alimentaire ?
Encore une fois, la réponse est non.
C'est encore une autre crise du savoir sur les ressources agricoles de l'Afrique,
lesquelles et où elles sont,
et comment elles peuvent être mieux gérées pour réussir
à faire que les Africains vivent plus de vies
qui valent le coup d'être vécues.
Sinon, comment expliquer le fait
que la géographie met la source du Nil en Éthiopie,
et que son peuple ne puisse pas avoir de l'eau pour vivre ?
Et la même géographie met la Californie dans le désert,
mais c'est un grenier.
La différence, de toute évidence, n'est pas la géographie.
C'est la connaissance.
Les aquifères du Colorado
font pousser les pistaches de Californie.
Pourquoi les aquifères de Libye ne pourraient-elles pas
faire pousser du sorgho dans le nord du Nigeria ?
Pourquoi le Nigeria n'aspire-t-il pas
à nourrir le monde,
pas seulement lui-même ?
Si la terre de l'Afrique est si pauvre, comme on nous le dit souvent,
pourquoi les gens de l'extérieur,
des Émirats Arabes Unis jusqu'à la Corée du Sud,
achètent de vastes superficies de notre terre,
pour cultiver de la nourriture, pas moins,
pour nourrir leur population
dans des terres qui sont vraiment privées sur le plan géographique ?
Les nouveaux propriétaires n'ont pas l'intention d'importer de la terre
pour rendre leurs acquisitions d'Afrique plus arables.
Encore une fois, un cas singulier de lacune de connaissances.
Au 19ème siècle,
nos prédécesseurs,
quelques années après les ravages de l'esclavage et la traite des esclaves,
exploraient les fleuves Niger et Congo
en vue de transformer les ressources de l'Afrique à l'avantage de son peuple
et pour le reste de l'humanité,
et leurs successeurs du 20ème siècle rêvaient de l'exploitation
de la puissance du fleuve Congo
pour éclairer l'ensemble du continent.
Non seulement les capitalistes flibustiers d'Europe
prévoient de faire la même chose,
mais pour les exportations vers l'Europe et l'Afrique du Sud.
Et ils suggèrent même
que les Congolais ne peuvent bénéficier de ce réseau,
parce que, selon eux, les communautés congolaises sont trop petites
pour rendre leur fourniture d'électricité
une solution viable.
La solution ?
L'Afrique doit devenir une société de la connaissance,
une caractéristique de l'âge moderne.
Nous ne sommes pas sur le chemin de devenir
une société de la connaissance.
Les choses n'ont pas toujours été ainsi
quand il s'agit de la production du savoir et de l'Afrique.
Dans l'antiquité, le monde s'est rendu en Afrique pour l'enrichissement intellectuel.
Ils célébraient des centres d'apprentissage,
attirant les chercheurs de toutes les parties du monde connu d'alors,
à la recherche de connaissance à propos de ce monde.
Ce qui est arrivé alors a des conséquences sur notre présent.
Par exemple,
comment l'Afrique romaine a géré les relations entre colons et autochtones
entre le deuxième et quatrième siècles de notre ère
pourrait avoir quelque chose à nous apprendre quand il s'agit de faire face
à des problèmes pas si différents à l'heure actuelle.
Mais combien de départements classiques avons-nous dans nos universités ?
Parce que nous n'investissons pas dans la connaissance,
les gens viennent en Afrique maintenant
non pas dans un lieu d'enrichissement intellectuel,
mais dans un endroit où ils rassasient leur soif d'exotisme.
Pourtant, durant le dernier demi-millénaire,
l'Afrique a été le lieu de l'hémorragie et de l'exportation de connaissances
vers le reste du monde.
Quelle que soit la description populaire comme un commerce de personnes,
la traite transatlantique des esclaves et l'esclavage
ont été l'un des plus longs et des plus radicaux des programmes
de l'exportation des cerveaux africains dans l'histoire.
Les propriétaires d'esclaves américains peuvent avoir feint
de croire que les Africains n'étaient
que de simples brutes, des bêtes de somme,
presque aussi inertes et muets que les autres outils agricoles
qu'ils recensaient dans leurs registres.
Et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait.
Les esclaves africains, d'autre part,
savaient qu'ils étaient des représentations de la connaissance.
Ils étaient forgerons, ils étaient poètes,
ils étaient conseillers politiques, ils étaient des princes et princesses,
ils étaient mythologues, ils étaient herboristes
ils étaient chefs.
La liste est sans fin.
Ils ont, pour prendre un seul exemple,
apporté la connaissance de la culture du riz
dans le Sud des États-Unis.
Ils ont créé certains des éléments de civilisation les plus originaux
pour lesquels les États-Unis sont maintenant célèbres.
Ils ont déployé leur connaissance, pour la plupart,
sans indemnisation.
Durant le dernier demi-millénaire, à commencer par le commerce des esclaves,
l'Afrique a exporté des cerveaux
tout en brisant les chaînes de la transmission des connaissances
sur le continent lui-même,
avec de terribles conséquences pour les systèmes de production du savoir
en Afrique.
Les générations successives furent coupées de la production intellectuelle
de leurs prédécesseurs.
Nous continuons à produire pour les marchés extérieurs
en compromettant nos propres besoins internes.
A l'heure actuelle,
une grande partie de la meilleure connaissance de l'Afrique
n'est ni produite ni hébergée là-bas,
même lorsqu'elle est produite par les Africains.
Parce que nous sommes dominés par des besoins immédiats
et des solutions pertinentes quand il s'agit de ce que nous devrions savoir,
nous sommes heureux de remettre à d'autres
la responsabilité de produire des connaissances,
y compris les connaissances à propos de, et pour nous,
et ce, loin de nous.
Nous sommes toujours désireux de consommer la connaissance
et n'avons qu'une simple partie de celle-ci
sans aucune inquiétude au sujet de la propriété et l'emplacement.
Les universités africaines sont maintenant toutes très satisfaites
d'avoir des connexions internet avec les bibliothèques d'ailleurs,
ayant renoncé à leurs ambitions sur la construction de bibliothèques
où le monde serait venu pour son édification intellectuelle.
Le contrôle sur qui décide ce qui devrait être stocké sur nos étagères
et l'accès aux collections doivent être déterminés
en se reposant sur notre confiance en nos partenaires de bonne foi,
qui ne nous abandonneront pas en cours de route.
Cela doit changer.
L'Afrique doit devenir un lieu de connaissance à nouveau.
La production du savoir étend l'économie.
Prenez des fouilles archéologiques, par exemple,
et leur impact sur le tourisme.
Nos désirs de déterrer notre antiquité,
en particulier les temps reculés dont nous n'avons pas de documents écrits,
nécessite un investissement dans l'archéologie et les disciplines connexes,
par exemple, la paléoanthropologie.
Pourtant, même si c'est notre passé que nous cherchons à savoir,
par pur hasard,
l'archéologie peut faire la lumière sur l'expérience humaine à l'échelle mondiale
et mener à des retours économiques
qui ne faisaient pas partie des raisons originales pour creuser.
Nous devons trouver un moyen de faire du savoir et sa production
quelque chose de sexy et d'enrichissant.
Enrichissant, non pas dans le sens grossier du gain d'argent
mais pour que cela vaille la peine de se livrer à la recherche de la connaissances,
soutenir l'existence
des groupes de production de connaissances et d'intellectuels,
s'assurer que le continent
devienne le centre immédiat de la production de connaissance,
de la distribution et de la consommation,
et qu'au lieu d'avoir ses archives
au-delà des frontières de l'Afrique,
une fois de plus les gens viennent du reste du monde,
même dans l'espace virtuel, pour apprendre de nous.
Tout ce que nous faisons en tant que dépositaires au nom de l'humanité commune.
La création d'une société du savoir en Afrique,
pour moi, serait une façon de célébrer et simultanément améliorer la diversité
par un enrichissement infini de matière et d'autres artefacts --
des artefacts que nous fournissons
par nos efforts
dans le domaine des connaissances.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)